SCSCOROREDED F FOROR  MIMIAMAMI.
>>>> J Jefeff:f: WEWELLLL,, G
HEHE'S'S N NOWOW I INN T THIHIS6
AA C CRARAFTFTYY K KYLYLEE L LO
TUTURNRNOVOVERER
AA C CRARA
CECELTLTICICS S TRTRYIYINGNG T .
HEHE I ISS A A D DIFIFFEFERERENT
PRPRITITCHCHARARD D THTHOUOUGHG.
>>>> M Marark:k: T TOO MEME,,
ITIT'S'S G GOTOT T TOO B BEE T
TOTOO O MUMUCHCH I IN N HIHIS S.
TATATUTUMM W WASAS O ONN H HIMI.
HEHE W WASAS YWEWELLLL
PHPHYSYSICICALALITITY,Y, T THEH
CACAUSUSININGG T THEHE C CHAHAOS
ONONLYLY S SEVEVENEN F FOROR M .
BUBUTT T THAHAT'T'SS A ANN O OF
ONON A ANN A AWKWKWAWARDRD R RE
OLOLADADIPIPOO H HADAD S STRTRI
BABATT S SHOHOTT L LOOOOKK
LILIKEKE T THEHERERE W WASAS S E